الأضواء الشمالية
بالنسبة للكثيرين ،
أصبح من الصعب الآن وضع علامة على عنصر قائمة الجرافات النهائية بفضل قيود الحركة
الوبائية الـ 19 السرية التي
تمرر الصحية
المسافات الاجتماعية ، كل هذا جعل
السفر التقليدي صعبًا للغاية
بعد أن بدأ الوباء ،
قررت شركة الأضواء فوق لابلاند عدم تقديم
أي جولات لـ  أحدث
موسم للشفق القطبي من أجل سلامة
الموظفين والضيوف
بدلاً من ذلك شاركوا عبر الإنترنت مجموعة من
الواقع الافتراضي وجولات 360 درجة
التقطوها قبل أن تبدأ البلدان
في الإغلاق ، أدركنا أن كل
هذه اللقطات التي لدينا كانت طريقة رائعة
لعرضها  العالم الذي لا يزال هناك
جمال طبيعي الآن من خلال
الواقع الافتراضي ، يمكن أن يجلب الثلج إلى أريكتك
بعد أن حاولت وفشلت في رؤية
أضواء الشفق قبل أن يعجبني
أن هذه المرة مضمونة وبينما
سأفتقد الروائح الهواء البارد المنعش
الشوكولاتة الساخنة على النار وبعض
النعال المريحة على قدمي ليست بديلاً سيئًا
لمغامراتي في القطب الشمالي تمامًا
مثل هذا  لقد انتقلت إلى
أرض سويديّة ثلجية مغطاة بالثلوج
وبدأت رحلتي في فندق الجليد المشهور عالميًا ،
إنه أمر مذهل ، لقد
أردت دائمًا الذهاب إلى فندق الجليد قبل
القفز على مزلقة الرنة
عبر البرية في القطب الشمالي ،
هذا مذهل
، ثم أخيرًا العرض الكبير
من الزلاجات التي تجرها الكلاب إلى أضواء التزلج على الجليد في
مجموعة لابلاند ،
تقدم جولات شخصية على مدار العقد الماضي
بعد نشر مقاطع فيديو الواقع الافتراضي هذه التي تكلف
حوالي اثني عشر ألف دولار
لجعل الشركة تقول إن حركة مرور الويب
لديها تضاعفت أربع مرات في غضون أسبوع.
أقول إنني كنت أعتقد دائمًا
أن الواقع الافتراضي كان وسيلة للتحايل ، كان لدي
شركاء عمل سابقون
يريدون حقًا السير في مسار الواقع الافتراضي ولكي أكون
صريحًا جدًا لم يكن لدي أي اهتمام ، ولكن
يومًا ما أحضرني أحد المرشدين الجدد
رجل نبيل اسمه هندريك
زوج من النظارات مثل تلك التي أملكها
ورائي هنا ، قال تشاد انظر إلى هذا ،
لذا ارتديته على مضض منذ تلك
اللحظة ،
كنت مدمن مخدرات تمامًا
ونفهمه  قبل أن يضرب الوباء مباشرة ،
كان هذا شيئًا أه سيكون
وسيلة رائعة للناس للسفر في
المستقبل يحلمون بركوب الدراجات ،
فالشركة السويدية ليست وحدها كل من
مجلس السياحة الألماني إلى المعالم التاريخية في المملكة المتحدة
يستفيد من الواقع الافتراضي
و  الواقع المعزز
لجذب زوار جدد وتعزيز
تجارب الزائرين الحاليين ، لذا فإن 360
درجة مثالية لصناعة السياحة
حيث يمكنك حقًا أن تُظهر
للناس ما يتوقعونه من الناس في
الواقع قبل الذهاب في عطلة
يمكنهم بالفعل إلقاء نظرة على
غرفة أو كيف سيكون الشاطئ أو حتى
كيف سيبدو القارب مثل
هؤلاء المرشدين السياحيين يقولون إن استثمارهم
في الواقع الافتراضي يعني المزيد من الحجوزات للمستقبل
أكثر من أي وقت مضى
حيث يتطلع مراقبو النجوم المحتملون إلى استبدال
الواقع الافتراضي
بصندوق باندورا الواقعي  تم فتحه
ويفهم الناس كيف يمكنهم السفر
حول الكوكب دون مغادرة منازلهم ،
لذلك أتوقع أن يستمر في
النمو إلى النقطة التي  نحن بصدد إنشاء
جولات الواقع الافتراضي الجديدة للمستقبل ،
وأعتقد أن بعض الأشخاص الذين
يشاهدون جولة الواقع الافتراضي لن يأتوا لزيارتها أبدًا
لمجرد أنها بعيدة المنال ، لكنني أعتقد أيضًا
أن جولات الواقع الافتراضي ستثير
الاهتمام وستقود الناس للحضور إلى
جولاتنا  وقد رأينا في الواقع بعض
الحالات التي شاهد فيها الأشخاص الجولة
عبر الإنترنت والآن يريدون رؤيتها في
الحياة الواقعية التي كانت بمثابة انتقال رائع.